i'll start with you real quick just
about uh recent progress uh how do you
feel things are going and any updates
you'd like to
mention sure i think last time we talked
we
talked about having several plans that
were in the works
that we felt were finally starting to
bear fruit and one of those
is the 200 welfare workers went through
three weeks of training so they would be
able to help claimants
with both pua and ui issues and many of
them have both
so they just finished their first week
of
actually working on those claims and
they got through just about 5 000
of them uh so that is uh those are the
kinds of numbers we were hoping to
see and they'll they'll uh we gave them
a refresher training kind of
go over some specific questions that
came up in their first week
and we think they'll be able to continue
to make that kind of
good progress and mostly those are
pula folks who kind of have both issues
that need to be resolved
so we're very pleased with that uh and
the
other progress we've made as we switched
over uh elorica's last day running the
call center was
on saturday and we've switched it over
to
a dieter managed call center
that started this morning and so far so
good
and the difference there is the folks
who are answering the phones can also
handle both pua and ui questions and
progress for claimants and we think that
that's really going to help
uh resolve sort of these complicated
issues that people are having
and on the topic of the the
call center what's the point of having
it in-house just to
let people know to to get rid of the
lorca and move it back to deer
yeah the plan always was that it would
come back in-house because the
pua program which olorica was hired to
answer questions for
expires in december so we always were
going to have to bring it back
the reason we moved that up earlier was
that we were finding
a large number of folks in the pua
system
really needed to be able to have someone
to
look at their claim in both pua and
regular ui
uh because if you had regular ui wages
any time for the past year and a half
we need to be able to see that to get
you in the proper place and get your
claims filed in the proper system
so just because the growing number of
claims that
had both issues we felt it was important
to bring it back
and be able to answer both sets of
questions
barbara is there anything you wanted to
mention on that progress that she just
elaborated on
um we spent a lot of time adding
staff to be able to address the backlog
and the cases that continue to come in
and
so i feel like we've made tremendous
progress
with the addition of these 200
welfare eligibility workers and 75
new call center staff so i think you'll
begin to see as we're already seeing
more of the backlog being addressed and
just as importantly
no creation of a backlog for those that
are filing now
um those two are well for workers and
correct if i'm wrong they're going to be
actually calling people right well
um let me clarify you're going to be
processing cases
there are many cases that they don't
need to call the claimant
they can look at their file and what
they've already
submitted and approve their claim for
payment
or determine that they should be in ui
instead of pua send them a determination
telling them that so they can establish
their ui
claim they absolutely may reach out to
call the person
too but they may just not
need to and will again just be resolving
the claim
but we we have had a few people not
respond when they have
called so there are some calls being
made
okay is there any um anything people
should know about those people calling
phone number area codes or anything like
that
uh i'm pretty sure it's going to be
coming from a general
state phone number
so if they are getting an unknown
call from a 684
number or a 486
number in las vegas uh it's
it could potentially be uh one of uh
either our staff or the welfare staff
calling them
to verify some information uh
get additional information or just sort
of give them an update on their
their claim so they should definitely
answer that
uh if they possibly can and we know
that our the folks who are making these
calls out are calling at least three
times
so if if you couldn't get to your phone
they'll be calling you back
probably in the same shift so you should
definitely try and answer that call
and get those issues resolved if
possible
okay and so uh some of the chatters uh
having a tough time getting through on
the phones is what's the suggestion for
people with that is it still
just keep trying or what is your uh
suggestion
well hopefully today with the new team
taking over the pool call center those
um concerns will decrease
we always know that monday is the worst
day to call right in almost any system
right
dmv the doctors you name it
uh they usually say you know wednesday
thursday or better days than monday and
tuesday
but we're hoping less complaints come as
a result of the
takeover of the pool call center
and again since those if someone files
for pua
and they should be in the ui system
and that one worker is able to help them
then that's one less call going over to
the ui call
center so again we're hoping the
addition of personnel
hopes and stabilizes both systems
perfect all right i don't know if elisa
or barbara are you guys able to give me
any sort of uh i know it's a 5 000
um last week which is which is good are
we able to compare
what we've been doing recently to what
we've been doing a couple months ago
just to give people sort of idea
well the the welfare workers are
completely new to the
system and they're working in both um
they're working in both systems so
really there aren't any comparable
numbers because the two
uh the two call centers were working uh
separately
so i don't really have any
um comparable numbers at this point to
share
um yeah i
i'd have to go back and look and see
what kind of reporting we had before
that i do know that the
call volume has come down quite a bit uh
in the pool call center um and i think
it's because we
we have been able to do a
notification to a lot of folks that
they're they should be in the ui system
so that move move those calls over to
the regular ui
call center
[Music]
so we could i could see what we have in
terms of
call volume that i could share with you
okay
i don't have anything off top my head
but it they're they're
now quite different systems yeah um
alisa
i don't know if we could um highlight
for joe some of the
um uh the notice of ineligibility
determinations that will be going out
yes we are working with uh
the the vendor geosol
to set up uh notifications as you know
fraud has been an issue for every state
in the country in the pua system and
uh we have been able to do a few mass
notifications
for folks that we haven't been able to
um
that that had the ui wages and now the
next sort of mass notification we want
to do is for
for claims where we haven't been able to
verify identity
so that should be coming in the next few
weeks
where we'll be able to send out a mass
notification
saying we've determined that you're
ineligible because we can't verify
your identity allowing folks an
option to appeal or possibly go through
id me
to to say no i'm i'm a real person that
got stuck in this
so it should sort of speed most of those
cases
of real folks to resolution and also
allow us not to have to keep reworking
claims that we think
are not valid claims so that we can
sort of more quickly move to the people
who are eligible
so um folks should be looking for that
as well
in case they somehow get caught up in
that and then they can quickly either
verify their identity or appeal their
case to us so it can
get processed is there anything you want
to mention on that i didn't know if you
yeah um there'll be there'll be about 9
000 of those going out shortly that's
uh people that did not um follow through
with id me
and we believe almost all of those are
fraudulent claims
so it's significant progress to be able
to send those ineligibility
determinations
to unclog the system and then of course
at the same time we've identified the
remainder of the claims that we think
are valid
and those are being those have been
distributed
either through huawei adjudicators
the welfare workers and other staff
to get those processed as soon as
possible
so we feel like we're reaching
you know we're seeing light at the end
of the pua tunnel
and i think you're going to continue to
see that over the next
couple weeks will this do this
notification will that
alleviate um the work that's being
they're trying to figure out to
verify someone's identity is that just
kind of creating more of a backlog
because they're trying to figure this
identity out and by setting that
notification now and it might
clear that up to get others through
right is that
that's exactly right it clogs up the
system every time
someone stops to look at someone who
is part of a fraud ring it's time not
spent on a nevadan that needs help and
we gotta connect the nevadans with their
benefits so weeding out the fraudsters
focusing on those that are eligible
until everything is cleared out that's
the goal
on that topic of fraud i mean we've been
covering this obviously for a while now
and
you've been seeing people filing from
out of state out of country
um have you noticed anything different
lately is there is there anything you
have some comments on that or do you
think that
um it's sort of inconsistent with what
they were saying before
um i think you know we've put several
measures into place
uh where we're able to
better sort of determine whether a case
is a
legitimate claimant or a fraudulent
claim
so we've asked folks in the pua system
for example to upload their
documents and um and then
based on sort of how they respond to
that request
that helps us sort of sort things out uh
and so there are
several claims that are fairly active
that are
moving forward to be evaluated and
continue to be processed
and then several others that are likely
to be
determined ineligible once we get that
notification to go out
so uh i think that we're we're seeing
um uh and i
haven't been following other states very
closely but i think that
if once people see that there are fraud
protection measures in place
uh then they move on to other states to
see how they're
how they'll fare there and certainly
we've seen
sort of spikes in cases uh initial
claims in other states
that suggest that people are just
continuing to
see where they can best uh perpetrate
these frauds
um so hopefully on our case initial
claims are coming down in both systems
so i think uh that also is reflective of
a little bit that the economy is picking
up in some places here
but also that we're not seeing as many
fraudulent claims being filed
perfect okay um i know
barbara last time was the last interview
maybe the one before that we had talked
about overpayment concerns and
and there were some things that were
going to be addressed when it comes to
overpayments
um i knew that pool wasn't around
obviously before is there any
any changes with with that or is
everything still the same i think you
mentioned
that you guys are going to be meeting
something regarding overpayments
yeah we we hope to reach some resolution
on that
this week um we we needed to
kind of re-look at the different
programs right because of course pillow
wasn't around before
so we're we're examining that and hope
to have some additional guidance on that
out this week
and when you say uh on that is there any
specific part of overpayments that
you're talking about
well um what we want to try to do is
have a good balance right
if someone can uh repay
an overpayment that accrued in the past
that they hadn't taken care of before
in order to establish eligibility we'd
like that to happen if we can
well we have different systems we have
different eligibility for the different
systems we have different computer
systems
so we're ironing that out so we can give
better guidance to the claimants
perfect all right um another big thing
obviously i'm sure you guys have gotten
bombarded with questions regarding the
300
weekly payments from the fema that whole
thing
can we give any uh insight on to where
we're at with that
yes um so we we said when we were
approved uh
which is about three weeks ago that it
would take four to six weeks
and we're definitely looking at being
able to process these
payments within the four to six week
window so the next three weeks here
we're in testing right now to make sure
that it
goes smoothly and we'd rather take a few
more days
and test it and make sure it rolls out
smoothly then
try and rush it and then have a whole
bunch of create a bunch of new problems
so
um i think we're in the next three weeks
people should expect to see this they
don't need to do
anything additional to get the benefit
and if you're in pua
and you were paid those weeks in august
uh the
the everybody that was eligible in pua
will also be eligible for lost wages
uh remember in the regular ui system you
have to
have made a minimum of a hundred dollar
weekly benefit amount
to qualify for the lost wages amount
so uh not everybody who got paid
unemployment uh in august the first
three weeks of august will
qualify for lost wages unfortunately
um and we're just we're we
it's a very it's a fixed amount of money
so we're
trying to get more guidance from the
department of labor
in terms of the extra weeks what happens
because
people also have continued to file
claims
and so there's more people that are
going to qualify than we originally
projected would be getting the benefit
so
we don't know how many weeks we're going
to be able to pay our goal is to pay as
many people as many weeks as possible
but in the next three weeks that should
that
that program functionality should be up
and running and then remember before you
said
as soon as that money comes through you
might be able to apply for
another another three weeks of it
roughly is that still something that's
happening or
what should people expect with that it's
just one time the first few weeks or
was it potentially more we did apply for
the second
three weeks uh and again it's
because it comes from a different pot of
money it's
fema money and so it once it hits a
certain
threshold at fema the funding stops so
we are
doing an analysis right now to see how
much
uh how far the money that we get will go
um so we're just we don't want to commit
to folks
whether they'll get any additional weeks
until we have
some certainty from uh and clarification
from the department of labor the first
three weeks we
were are solid uh and as many weeks
after that as we can possibly cover
and we're just looking for clarification
from the department of labor and fema on
them
so um just so it could be as soon as
probably before the end of this month
you'd guess right yes
that is yes that was our commitment
that's still our commitment before the
end of this month
yeah um appeals i know appeals
is uh a lot of people are talking about
that as well a lot of people waiting for
appeals
um where are we at with that and should
people be
getting notifications when it comes to
their appeals um
their appeal really
um the appeals capacity
the first part of the module exists so
people can
file their appeal what we still are
waiting on
with the vendor is the ability to
schedule the appeals
so that that piece we're still waiting
on um
we hope to have those going by the end
of this month for sure
uh and um we are in the process of
training
uh appeals refs uh so that they are
conversant
and ready to go once those appeals start
getting scheduled
uh we have discussed you know are there
ways to speed it up but
really um even if we went back to the
old school
sort of manual way we did this you have
to compile all the documents so you
you really need the system to
put the appeal together to fairly get
a consideration of all of a person's
documentation
so the best way is just to get it up and
running in terms of the scheduling but
we do think that will be
uh available by the end of the month as
well okay
barbara is there anything you want to
weigh in on the appeals
no we're anxious to get them going okay
and um
just because i've talked to several
people who have filed an appeal and they
don't
know what they're specifically waiting
for when you say notification will that
come to an
email or a letter how does that work and
what should people expect
after um i guess they get a date right
right i'm pretty sure they get something
in the mail
that tells them the date of their
hearing they can uh
i i haven't seen the final notification
so i'm
i'm speaking from sort of what i know
about how it works
uh so i may have to double check on this
but they
they will get a notice of when the
hearing is scheduled if they need to
reschedule they can contact us and do
that
and they're given their sort of their
due process rights
um so what the process looks like
they can bring somebody with them if
they'd like
and just kind of the question that's
going to be decided and appeal
for a lot of folks before they even get
to this point and this is happening
right now
we do have a team reviewing all the
appeal requests
and um we're finding that about 25 to 30
percent of them
truly have a decision that is appealable
and they're in a lot of cases they're
able to
um resolve just to
make a correction or update a decision
that was made and get them
moved through the process without having
to wait for an appeal so that's actually
uh for the folks that are waiting for
that capability to come online
a lot of them will just get an issue
resolved or
something corrected in their forms so
that their
their case can move forward which would
be a much better bet
much better outcome for them yeah i'm
guessing that would um alleviate
a bigger backlog of appeals come time
for hearings
obviously uh has that been going on
since the game since this
started is that something that's already
been going on
yes um it's been happening you know
recently
um where the workers are going through
and some for example will say
um you know my claim is my identity is
legitimate i
uploaded the documents please look right
and they'll look and they'll be there
and so their claim will get approved um
some have been as simple as that and in
the end that saves so much time
right people aren't waiting longer than
necessary
but some of them are this just isn't
fair
why was the law created this way well
that's not a legitimate appeal that's
something you can
bring to your congressional delegation
right that the
for example there's a lot of people
claiming it
complaining rightly so
that they're being forced to go into ui
when pua is the majority of their income
and that is a legitimate issue it is
wrong in my opinion it's a flaw
in the law right but that
is the laws that exist right now and
um so there's you know there's nothing
that
dieter can do about that but i spend a
lot of time
talking to claimants who are
um confused and upset about that portion
of the law
as a matter of fact i spoke to catherine
cortez masto's um staff about it just
last week
it's affected a lot of folks in the
entertainment industry
especially um if people have questions
regarding
not only appeals but anything else what
what's what's the top thing for you guys
to say
is it to call is it to uh is there an
email outlet they could do i mean what's
the best way for people to get through
i would i would say at this point
there's a couple of things one
you know there there are handbooks uh
online
there's um you know guidance online that
they could educate themselves
i realize it's a complicated system
so that's not an easy task but there are
a lot of frequently asked questions on
the website
that would be possibly the first place
to go to get an understanding
uh at this point i believe that the the
call centers probably
are the fastest uh way to
you know get an update if you really
want to talk to a person
about where you are and
you know and then just we are working
as uh you know focusing our resources on
being able to process the largest number
of claims and
and i i wish we could
get to the point and we will soon get to
the point where we can say
okay we're into sort of regular
uh operating it takes about three weeks
to get to process your claim and we're
we're probably closer to you know
looking at six
or seven weeks for folks um
depending on what the issue is and which
line they're in
uh but that's our goal is always to get
down to sort of a regular processing
amount of time for people
and then it's just you have to wait for
your
claim to go through the system and have
a person look at it
or or whatever needs to be done um
so long answer to a question where the
short answer is
probably the the call center is the best
place to get an answer
and with the additional staff i'm
guessing that might change now right
yes that's right and the more claims
that are processed
the less questions people have so we
feel like we'll be making progress on
all fronts soon
uh i'm almost done here but uh the
backlog do you feel like you're making a
pretty good dent in that bad luck i know
when
both of you took your rolls there was a
substantial backlog um
i don't know the number but thousands uh
how do you
how do you feel it's going well the um
in the um ui um system
you know we've processed over 50 15 000
in the backlog
and
higher and higher every week as the
staff is trained
and you know same with pua as we
process the remaining claims send out
the denials on the rest
i i think you're going to continue to
see
faster and faster resolution perfect
all right so anything else you uh either
of you like to say before we wrap this
up here about um
any future progress that's anything
that's in the works
any changes uh you know
congress is apparently talking about
another package of some kind
so our hope is that it looks like one of
our existing packages that we can
just add to uh but uh
you know uh that's we will do whatever
it takes to get
whatever is past implemented if it comes
our way
uh it just every every new program adds
a bunch of new wrinkles so i'm hoping
it's an existing program that gets
extended
and i hope with one change i hope that
they don't force
pua claimants to go to the ui system
when their ui wages are an insignificant
part of their income
i think we could make that change in our
state pretty quickly
and it would give a lot of relief to a
lot of people
yes about if we could just process them
in one system rather than two
um yeah that would that would be that
would be good i think the other thing i
would
say that folks should know is coming is
uh
that every quarter we are required to go
back and look at
you know your last quarter's earnings
and we just passed another quarter
so there may be some some more people
that are
moved from one system to the other based
on their
uh you know what happened what what they
were doing in the workforce a year and a
half ago
because that's how far back we go so um
i that is something we can't change is
we have to
reevaluate everyone's wages every
quarter
so that's coming too perfect all right
let me stop